you know when welcome to this video
playing dhaka dr. john Dunn you see
allowing me yes we had another Kings in
yella these are always entertaining I've
got a plus one score against himself not
unhappy about this pairing let's see how
he does it this time in the Petrosian we
had one game where I had a fantastic
position out of the opening ruling this
is probably not going to be repeated man
with f5 he plays it ok h5 is a bit more
comment yep like this yeah I know this
dispute x2 is not supposed to be that
great but this is with without f5 so
maybe I can do it here and it's not an
illogical home anyway yeah Queen g5 but
Mr not playing before immediately here I
understand 25 but then that's not be
three now it doesn't play that Wow h1
doesn't see 5 good for white that looks
good for white comment I don't believe
that takes 94 and threatening d6
immediately why it is not good for white
please I mean Scott yes it's all Kings
side we can maybe take on e4 d6d sixth
and take and take let's that doesn't
sound
you don't understand what I'm talking
about I'm sorry about that it should be
more precise and island this and I was
thinking d6 pawn takes Bishop takes pawn
takes would be seven and then isn't that
good for white I've got 95 let's see
let's see if this is 95 immediately is
also pretty interesting it's not quite
clear where he goes to back to 28 I've
got 96 wins material but that can also
just good huh isn't that good he cannot
take on f3m know so I could just play
night if Knight takes e4 now for a good
position on Jan I take your phone and
I'm upon down then I only recognized
that now that actually sacrificed the
pawn for this position i also have clean
d525 might also just be good I have
enough time to figure it out completely
so let's play it King age 8 95 isn't
that pretty annoying d 7 is hanging g6
hanging it looks terrible
[Music]
it was pretty terrible yeah well would
be seven I can also play Queen takes e4
okay first Ruby seven okay 755 9555 that
doesn't it's not that great I can take
five that's not good he takes e4 is
definitely not bad just wonder there's
something better let's do it I take too
long him yeah so what is what was this
and he's got this check on you three yet
that he does he did something he needs
otherwise that would just fall apart
anyway but f-for at four what are you
doing against that and for context
doesn't work look takes rook takes Queen
takes Queen g six wins what's going on
here
maybe he needs screen f5 or something
now okay so this should cheer for
unfortunately it doesn't work I can just
take his five but I can also take here
hmm something better can I takes takes
Bishop t5 as he swindled out of this
yeah maybe he has anyway I mean that
quince trade it is not as great here in
this position okay I can take Jesus six
no we should see for I don't know if
this is good time learning not to move
the move the rock lamp oh I don't have a
tactic there now then have to play this
which is not that great so he has
definitely swindled him swindled me him
okay I know it's got to check on East to
try only three come on this is crazy it
was such a one-sided game and now we
swing on me
okay i still have rope hanging and 97 so
it's not it's not super easy maybe it
isn't actually that that lost him that's
possible the thing I mean the address my
position was just completely winning
let's absolutely sure
[Music]
I'll get a cup I've got those threads
here on the eighth-ranked yeah I need to
need to free my king here probably h3 is
correct ok I can take with the friggin
night you can take with the night of
course and I'm lost just take it no and
9 f 2 is good of course
maybe you maybe have something better on
what what is he thinking about what's
going on here check check check check
check check check check check black for
fix on time aha okay well yeah we both
had completed winning position so this
crap shoot whatever first I was
completely winning than he was so it's
just a gamble basically at the end yeah
so I mean here here white is just
winning of course that that must be when
everything else would be very strange
because every begs position is just so
uncoordinated with all the unprotected
pieces and and stuff okay so this isn't
this look t8 so 25 is too light by the
engine nightly forms also interesting
91 in higher well we have high evaluator
then then then my move third floor
window ok so this now we have rookies
seven of course also what's interesting
this kind of thing yeah now 95 95 for
Bishop c4 and he just about hangs on
here with this move I cannot take here
look at six well okay as a miracle move
that black media to not totally use
immediately okay in the way it was
wasn't you that clear between a science
also only move that doesn't instantly
lose yeah yeah it's not as great Maggie
I've he had lost control text a group
before okay can I add event over looked
at them and now now I should be cash
would be lost with this board itself
somehow okay do you wandered across the
big deal there or was he thinking from
for that long k can just rock edge to
isn't that winning ok no look hu I was
thinking this would win easily yeah I
don't have to take on age three and then
and then it nets the nets and nessa
bishop of check your graduate oneself
and now it was complete chaos
okay then five against nine seconds so
check okay okay yeah I don't know need
to analyze it's just again a crapshoot
Jackson amazed that this wallet totally
lost it looks like these two completely
terrible this year I click complete a
terrible if some a promo medieval I hope
be seven still like they're probably
really additional here where I keep this
options open of queen bee hive and and
everything what is the preferred move a
935 goodbye the computer and clean these
three ticks ticks just want to see what
the that's the line the engine get it
also looks pretty pretty bad too black
anyway if the engine gives 20.8 and such
a position it is very likely just right
anyway thanks for watching